- Now, do you have your dog
with you on tour all the time?
- Madeline Kahn Chenoweth
has a bad heart now
and she can't fly,
and I wish so badly I
could travel with her.
I miss her when I'm not there,
but I do have a girl called
Natalie that stays with her--
- You almost called your
dog sitter Madeline.
(laughs)
Do you ever accidentally
call her Madeline,
which is your dog's name?
- Probably.
(laughs)
- Okay, that's alright.
- Matalie, Matalie. Her name's Natalie.
- Okay.
(up-tempo music)
- My two dogs, Larry and Pompom,
Larry is what I call "special needs".
- Don't say that about Larry.
- [Kathy] Sorry.
- He can hear you.
- I know, yes, okay.
He's not the sharpest pencil in the box,
but he's all love.
- [Kristin] He's the sweetest.
His legs are getting weaker,
and so I just call him Wheels,
'cause I think it's only a matter of time
before I just chop off his
legs and put those wheels on.
You know, the wheels on the
bus go 'round and 'round.
But the bad thing is, my
house has a lot of stairs.
So the day that I--
- I can't even go up and down them.
- Exactly. So I think he'll
have wheels for like a day
and then he'll just roll to his death.
- Don't you have an elevator?
- I do have an elevator,
and you know what, I've
actually thought about--
that's very Hollywood of me.
I may use my elevator
for my dog with wheels.